hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to avian another pixelated
style horror game and I have not played
one of these in a while not an RPG
horror which I'm going to play another
in a real short time here I'm talking
about the pixelated style horror games
like seven days lasting I see you I'm
scared all these great titles that
despite their low end graphics have
managed to scare the pants off of me
permanently because I never wear pants
people think that's actually a joke I'm
actually I never wear pants when I'm at
home because it is very comfortable I
want this shirt that someone sent me a
link to that says home is where the
pants aren't and that is exactly what I
want in my life but anyway I'm getting a
little off topic here these pixelated
style horror games actually represent
something really cool in my mind because
they they don't they don't emphasize
graphics and a lot of horror games do
ever set that is weird those kitties
should be cute as heck instead they're
rather disturbing
thank you little kitties for staring at
my soul have you always been there did I
just walk into the Kitty room of
nightmares I do not much appreciate
those things damn it why is everything
locked there must have been a key in
this kitten Roma nightmares oh there we
go can I get that go oh this is a small
hitbox and a note here how do I read my
note and um how do I read my note maybe
I shoulda looked at the instructions on
how to play before I started this
shindig oh oh there we go oh I think I
got something okay how do I do that I
got this I got the note I got oh I got
the note in my hand now I got the
flashlight in my hand now I got the key
in my hand okay so I got the key there
we go
I figured out what I'm supposed to do no
one told me what to do okay that is a
big wall of goop I as much as I like big
walls of goop I'm gonna go by that and
go over here to see what's in this room
filing cabinet a nothing in there wait a
minute no no no I had a little hitbox
there come on don't tell me there wasn't
I saw something did I get anything oh
wait no I got number three note okay
that's locked geez everything's locked
over here I think that someone's
paranoid about security some stranger
was gonna come walking in here
demons everywhere and then no one to get
anything else in there did I put those
in the sexual
[Applause]
you know kung-fu
crane grasshopper style but sexual oh I
was still alive the whole time I just
didn't do anything with it there we go
I figured out how to battery I was just
a friggin [ __ ] those as standing on the
darkness while everything was trying to
kill me don't you do that juice demon
cats what are you oh hi
someone went to Photoshop hell on you do
you want something from me Teddy K to
get a kitty no no little kitty meow meow
okey okey thank you I'm gonna go this
way and not die preferably so there was
one key that you put in here so the key
probably goes to the thing was the other
door over there
maybe the deal cell ok the key number 2
I'm finally starting to figure out how
no why would it go to there why would it
go to the convenient way to middle one
is that always there never mind that
Noah's re there I'm sorry I'm sorry ok
so I go this way yeah that's it hello
big plus signs I'm sorry
did not mean to touch your big plus
signs I will move on oh oh I get it I'm
supposed to rotate him
it's a puzzle but I have no idea how to
beat it so bear with me everybody I'm
gonna be here a while well obviously I
need to get all the blood signs
there we go LOD sign blood why did that
door it did I get it did I one yet he is
lying he doesn't know how to help you
remember only the closest brothers are
bound in blood
ah that is a clue that is a clue a clue
so you're talking like I need to put the
blood close to each other which means
that all the Bloods need to be close by
that rumbling Jerry something ah base on
this game it's something out the pack
blood brothers close I get it oh and
this is a room of flesh is this where
the sexual impossibilities come from I
forget what it actually said about
sexual something sexual acrobatics maybe
I miss a note no medication loofahs
Nazim haloperidol
olanzapine draw paradol sociopathy
patient applied for psycho psychiatric
treatment willingly no emotions were
triggered doing the blank test blank the
patient didn't respond to any stimuli
except for blank during the test 12a the
patient rose up from the chair and tried
to blank F EAC guards prevented possible
suicide the patient replied fill my life
wait all my life it is trying to get out
blank blank blank patient is showing
cooperation I will schedule fe AC
protocol preparation as soon as possible
I don't know what any of that means but
other portions
why did you have to be a son of a [ __ ]
about it
Kiki look at murky where's the key give
it to me please be nice to me
all that it's nice music that I've heard
from somewhere before
where's a big dog damn Kay - better give
me this key you son of a [ __ ] I'm not
gonna be walking around here and they're
dying enough go back to the beginning
that's not my life right now
give me that dictate my dad I'm dead
aren't I
I've dealt with it all my life just keep
calm and he will go away he isn't real I
bet he feels real not in the good way
calm down hey don't tell me what to do
foo grasshopper undulating style hi
hello there you look friendly time space
and partying has thawed fourteen
thousand five hundred and forty five
well now remaining
please wait a minute oh my god
are you kidding me flesh room oh my
goodness gracious
he isn't no oh my god I don't know where
that advice came from but it certainly
was bad oh this is getting interesting
oh one of the good things about these uh
pixelated [ __ ] games as they often ly
they often both emphasize on the
gameplay itself the ambiance and a story
I really like what's going on here I
like the twist I'm not really dead Am I
I don't have to go back to the beginning
of the game do I do
why is it dark please tell me what to do
where am i oh oh oh
where's my flashlight give me my
flashlight nope nope nope there give it
do it I thought I'd do it before get the
batteries in it come on give me by
flashlight how did I do it before my
flashlight what my flowers I died
okay there we go don't know what I did
but I did it back at the beginning okay
so it's not the beginning of the game no
no no ahh this is open so what do we
have here I need another note well
there's no number two so okay so that's
another thing patient hospitalized suit
a very degraded mental and physical
state or health during the initial
diagnosis the protocol the patient
approach one of the FE AC security
guards and tried to fight his arm after
plank he was that's why he did he tried
to bite the guards army or tied blue
search for the echoes of divine
knowledge after further studies the
patient refers to he as a divine entity
that communicates with him when he
drinks blood patient shows no sign of
cooperation proceed with termination so
they've killed me 14,000 times and it
just won't take so you're gonna have to
kill me fourteen thousand nine times and
mess with me in my case I will put C
caps in there don't want none of anyway
so can I use this knife to get through
this uh thingy thingy hey I can how
about that does that mean that if we go
in the hair again it'll be the flesh
room
I can't even not even open that door I
guess they don't want me to go back in
there Oh
let me do wha oh okay
something is my I'm mi I something is in
my eye but I will not wall falter Walter
well not Walter White I will not start
cooking meth and then destroy my family
even though I am the danger
I was Walter White if anyone wants to
know I was I played as him in the sketch
comedy over on nacho punch I'll put up a
link somewhere here if you guys really
want to see that oh hello
oh oh wait a minute
oh no I'm in the real world now what
real world calm down eosin real he'll go
away you can't be real calm down the
feeling that he's kind of real even if
he's in my mind the matrix taught me
that those things were real okay then
you found a tape recorder attached under
the plate okey-dokey what does it do now
we see that my colleagues real
intentions were never secured this year
the goal they are trying to accomplish
is borderline impossible yet they refuse
to listen to reason
the next area they'll apply some prefer
love you resent operation will be able
to kill you avoid him oh why do I want
that having constantly patrolling the
hallways if you hear she scream run for
your life huggy she can't get to you in
the rooms so close the doors behind
yourself also don't stay near the
hallway intersections for too long he
emerges from those places I know you'll
be surgical help all your life help me
stop them and I'll help you first that
thing from your mind
okay why do they why are they so
interested on this demon triangle head
thingy in my mind can I at least have
some bread and water
come on interest review good start
who the hell are you
are you my doctor wait a minute you
might doctor who's also God oh I gotta
lay down over here on the machine you
got it buddy
you got it friend oh I do whatever you
said to baby because I'm a good patient
crazy guy I actually am looking forward
to playing a few more longer series I
know you guys have been really asking
for it I'm gonna be playing more RPG
horror games that you guys suggested me
so if you got suggestions that you want
to play please write in the description
below I will be reading this game's
description very closely hello oh I'm
back in the room now so he's patrolling
the halls is he just stay away from the
hallway intersections huh well bring it
on I am a man of all muscle and no pants
you think that you could even stand a
chance against me probably could I'm
just saying maybe you shouldn't maybe
you shouldn't even try cuz I'm crazy
I've got I'm loaded up on diazepam or
whatever the thing is what is that what
is that it's not a screwdriver ah
don't put okay at one point I just
stopped counting slitting risk drinking
rat poison jumping off buildings nothing
seemed to work
I always saved you and always will if
you die I die okay then that's
interesting
are you talking to the guy out there
should I call him triangle head McGee
silly douche mcbutter nutter
I like silly douche mcbutter another
reminds me of my old French smitty
werben jaegerman jensen I've forgotten
it already I've literally forgotten the
name that I just gave him so I have no
idea okay I need more items if I want to
construct something okay so that's a
blowtorch Flint lighter whatever you
call that although the official name for
it and the other thing is either tongs
or really big chopsticks Hey you son of
a [ __ ] nobody's home get back
I am very dangerous kind of how much
money after you wasted you wasted so far
thinking you could erase me by drinking
no amount of stimuli can erase me are
you the guy talking triangle face
mcbutter nutter I don't remember what I
called you but not Eric but
face what face miss ass McGee mister
nipple tweak alibi good name mister
nipple tweak don't think that you can
escape for me mr. nibbles week she took
everything the house the car she
couldn't put up with your drinking but
you didn't want to tell her afraid I was
going to do something but mark My dear
fellow I am NOT right okay I have a good
feeling that you're real now
I just need to be very careful I don't
know what I'm trying to collect but
obviously I'm trying to construct
something I haven't seen you yet but
that doesn't mean that you're not
douchey nowhere in the corners what did
I call on my car forget something nipple
tweak I forget what I call them again
such an idiot
I don't remember anything I say when I'm
doing these recordings I just spout out
nonsense like at a million miles an hour
nothing gets recorded into memory I'm
actually that's actually a fun fact
whenever I looked back at my videos and
people say like oh this part was really
funny I'm like I don't remember saying
that at all
I've kind of unfiltered at the moment so
don't even bother with me all right so
anyway uh no three you try change jobs
thinking I would go away with the past
just like that you can read for yourself
I am nipple tweak mcbutter nutter you
cannot beat nipple tweak my butternut er
I'm spitting quite fruit peeler
profusely thanks thanks for that I like
that that's good you keep that up
you tried oh no that's not right um for
no no one this is where it all began at
first you blame fatigue stress no matter
how much sleep you had you saw me
nonetheless shadows danced for an
instant but they soon they started
dancing longer and longer so where the
sexual martial arts come in remember
that time at the gas station when you
want to set yourself on fire yeah fun
time I think I only need one more note
there's a total of six maybe I already
went in there look down here already
gone down here yeah hob go stay away
from the intersection
he's gonna get me no intersection
douchebag mother humper son of a [ __ ]
you're reviving me how many times do I
need to die on your patient table before
you let me die
well let's just be better to let me die
why do these people want this thing why
do people want nipple tweak mcbutter
nutter
can I get fair narrative nipple tweak
mcbutter number mcbutter number mechanic
butter I fit goddamnit I can't even talk
so don't ignore me okay okay thank you
was he right by me I don't know if he
was well good cause I think I saw
something I saw something in the
darkness oh wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute did I oh did I not
pick it up oh I have to go back and pick
it up all again dunker nutter dunker
flutter father-daughter father-daughter
okay get everything in the rooms I need
to make this a zig zag Rossi you all see
pattern so that's the beginning don't go
in the intersection he's not by me he's
patrolling the halls he is around here I
just didn't see him Ron's gonna let you
shut your mouth I know you're scared of
the monster out there but please try to
get some self-control you really thought
they could help you you really though
they could help you with their fancy
therapies and exercises well it's your
money that's going down the drain okay
see out here not giant steel door I need
to blow it up I need to blow it with my
Peter blow skills my impressive Peter
blow skills I'm just gonna make a big
loop around the entire room first and
then I'm gonna go into the inner rooms
no Sam come on give me a chance give me
a ding dong damn chance
oh you son of a [ __ ] we just cut out
you dickbag McFlurry nutter her nipple
tweak mcbutter nutter how dare you
I'm gonna call smitty werben jaegerman
jensen on you okay - I'm gonna go in the
inner doors this time and I'm not gonna
stay in the hallways for very long cuz
that's what they taught me I think oh
god what am I going oh god oh god oh god
oh god no what else do I need cause what
have I missed
I don't know another room that I've
already been do not kill me you son of a
[ __ ] I will kill you if you kill me God
I think I see him in the shadows every
once in a while crazy where is he
where's you don't give me don't get me
don't get me right here what do you got
yes what I don't know what I got battery
or something like that wait here till he
screams at me yeah that's right oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah I'm great the best the
best I otherwise I'm gonna build a bomb
and a lot B to blow you out of this
dimension nipple twist mcbutter nutter
how dare you first of all how dare you
second of all don't talk to me
oh don't don't get it whoa I got it oh I
made a blowtorch
okay so I'm gonna wait until he screams
again
okay maybe not it's better not you if
you I swear I swear this gaem if this
game decides to be a douche and it just
okay here we go
nothing criminy Christmas cracker jack
box nipple twist mcbutter nutter you son
of an ass oh god damn it you son of a
[ __ ] I think every time I hear the
scream I gotta turn around do not get to
me again I will be very upset I will be
very upset with you you will not
tolerate my anger it's going to be
unreal how much I will just throw my
disdain in your direction
damn you rogue you ain't got to get my
nipple twist nipple man my nipples are
untwist Abel made of diamond and
reinforced with carbon fiber and then I
rub some ice cubes on them in their
hearts no you killed me while I was
talking about my nipples why this is
really hard very hard I don't know if I
can go all day long with this oh man
nipple twist is really riding me I
expect the comments to just be filled
with that's what she said it has to be
if it's not I'm gonna be very
disappointed oh you almost got me that
time whoa but I am too smart for you I
am too smart and/or handsome and or not
both not both yeah that's right yeah
what's up no
yeah oh yeah get it got it good on the
man I just got to get out of here
that guy's gonna be a son of a [ __ ] I
haven't heard screaming a while gotta
make it from checkpoint to checkpoint
you gonna make it from doorway to
doorway there's specific places I can go
that I will not get in the hallway and
you will not chip my niblets do a lot
twist my nipples you will do anything to
my butt someone is very eager gotta go
now he's very eager yeah this is where
we part ways my friend
why yes looks like your theory was
incorrect right what he finally found
what we've been looking for all these
years my friend
[Music]
no never really could've industry
cricket
[Music]
put the dog down
okay okay what happened
am i the monster what did he do that was
that ever changes to my survival goodbye
where am i where am I now
what happened why happened why these
locked scum have no idea what is going
on here very cadiz oh welcome to DAC
your expression
cool and that is the deep voice entities
are walking off now follow us we speak
well my friends we play attack and smart
let's who will be working one of the
best psychologists and doctors from
around the world he's been assigned to
work on developing ways to through
severe paranoia a crippling fear that
divides in hearts of our enemies through
any means necessary
my things out there are nerves what a
key card slides from the projector did I
get it oh I got it okay oh no you don't
belong here
I guess Newman couldn't help me after
all you were and you never were real yet
the fear cripples me at least I'm free
from the doctors now
it's really weird that you're calling me
by my name finally I am oh those the end
oh that was really cool I was totally
into it I was totally into it
it was that part where it was really
douchey in there while I was trying to
get all the pieces and it was really
easy to die and it felt kind of random
and I don't know what I was doing wrong
at first but I figured it out I got
through it
that was awesome it was awesome those
fun those does this plain fun and you
don't get that out of horror games very
often either way that was an awesome
pixelated horror game oh excuse me there
are many other great pixelated horror
games you'll find a whole bunch linked
in the description below they're all
fantastic I've yet to play one that is
actually bad so check them out
there's also RPG horror games down there
if you want to give those a try as well
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation so obviously for
more videos that i've done and as always
i will se you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]